drapeaux à oui c'est comme si sûr il y à
quelques torts c'est lié au sujet de la
vidéo raconte pas ma vie pour rien j'ai
dû mettre la collerette de la montana
dessous de ce fameux [ __ ] d'entonnoir
directement sur sa tête
j'avais vu ce qu'il a fait dans des
films genre le chien il est nul quand il
a ça et on se moque de lui devant fait
qu'on fait qu'il est nul ce chien là
c'est mon chien qui a cette collerette
personnes se moquent là ok bon alors
pourquoi il a ça évidemment ce qui s'est
fait une petite plaie et l'arrêt pas te
toucher la plaie du coup elle s'est
infectée il faut qu'il arrête de la
touche et pour que la peau mate fasse
effet et du coup on met la collerette
pour les empêcher d'accéder à son propre
corps bref je suis très triste triste
mais regardez sa gueule [ __ ] et vient
évidemment qui fait de la peine
parallèlement je suis tombé sur un seul
vrai dit a pas très longtemps ou c'est
un symbole qui a pour but de rappeler
que les animaux aussi peuvent se
comporter comme des cons et là j'ai
besoin de voir ça pour ressentir moins
d'empathie de pitié envers natsu et pour
me rappeler que parfois il est un peu
têtu et vilains du coup peut-être qu'ils
méritent potentiellement ça collerait
bienvenue dans les abris dit annie
molding jerks dans lequel nous allons
voir des tas d'animaux se comporter
comme des [ __ ] et je sens que j'ai
beaucoup rire ça va faire du bien déjà
de voir des animaux souvenez-vous la
bâche
bref c'est parti heitz et je vous
entends rire la repasse en automne la
touche vous l'armée est là tout ce qu'on
rigolait vous êtes ben ali de la chaîne
vous n'avez plus droit de venir au quai
ce crabe avance sur un tuyau de la
boutique en retirant la peinture merci
pour le bordel salle aux attentes en mai
les cram qui ce qui se passe avec les
crabes déjà des enfants n'avait parlé
des crabes voleurs qui se bat avec tes
[ __ ] plutôt dans les pinces et voilà
qui reviennent assez tellement cette
saison de faire ça retirer les petits
bouts de peinture qui se détache le
comprendre et le crabe
mais ça fait des semaines qu'il en train
de faire ça c'est donc ça à toutes les
fois où j'ai vu un mur pas ouf
au lycée avec la peinture par terre en
fait c'est un crack qui était passé par
là on sous estime trop les crabes à
skieurs rencontre une marmotte d'accord
mais quand on dirait un dessin animé
on dirait un personnage de dessin animé
je suis désolé c'est quand même une
sacrée insultes qui ressemble à un
personnage de dessin animé
imaginez si vous vous dise or clément
gt1 mais les chats mexes un coin c'est
fou d'en avoir autant rien à [ __ ] et
arrêtez de vous faire vyckos par un chat
vous la bouger le peuple pour sa
sécurité et pour la vente un chat en
colère défend la maison d'un agent
immobilier attentats temps voulait dire
que il y à des chats de garde robe
ok quand quelqu'un qu'elle ait tous
quelques astuces ça fait plus peur
guéant qui dit qui y est ok elle a tenté
la petite voix pour l'amadouer
ça ne marche pas il en a rien à [ __ ]
il fait peur
il va sauter il va te sauter au visage
un film d'horreur mais que j'ai jamais
vu ça c'est pas dans non ce n'est pas ta
main comme ça s'il a été frappé il va se
livrer sa [ __ ] je me sens pas ça j'ai
pas des chats comme ça la [ __ ] moi
m'ont chassé sagro
je suis pas habituée aux lions la
sauvage là comme ça c'est arrivé à une
pote à moi ou genre sont shy'm est
devenu fou d'un coup et chez plus je
crois que c'est un syndrome jeu peu
commun s'appelle mais ton chat d'un coup
il redevient méga sauvage vraiment une
saute au cou et griffé tout c'est hyper
bas donc voilà lorsqu'un chat
habituellement canaries d'où devient
subitement agressif et violent envers
son maître on appelle ce comportement le
syndrome du tir l'animal est violent
agressif une source de danger pour
lui-même et pour son maître c'est pas
danser un syndrome très peu connue qui
arrive de temps à autre en ans et y est
on est tous trauma déjà à cause de la
vidéo plus de cette information sur
syndrome du type clément fils qu'il faut
montage te plaît pour que les gens
n'aient pas peur des chats après avoir
vu cette vidéo
aux deux petits chiens en plus tu as de
bons potes à balan pisser dessus c'est
ça la femme était sur voilà montrent
leur montre leur qu'elle garde à la
maison depuis dix ans te laisse pas
faire par les petits jeunes ce chaton ne
rigole pas oh mais c'est quoi ces
animaux qui sont d'un dessin animé mec
c'est quoi ce bordel d'un même mais sa
réaction
on dirait un disney ces genres de chiens
qui mangent des spaghettis c'est fou ok
ça a dû qu'à la thur chez les chats je
suis contente pas être un char là tu
vois time lapse d'une femme qui essaie
de dormir avec deux chats cdci à moi
c'est des siamois t'es mort les siamois
mec ça veut juste se coller de sa vie
pour se coller à toi tout le temps aulas
aulas en fait ce qui change c'est qu'ils
paris revient il pas ça y est notre zoom
manque c'est pour ça que je prenne un
sou pour tourner la vidéo c'est que
j'allais arrêter la vidéo pour juste
faire des câlins bonheur merci maman
annoncé encore on entre comme une maman
4 son chaton ier ce qu'est ce que c'est
égoïste on l'a dit relay chat rien au
monde n'a pu s'offrir la [ __ ] cash
assez fou la raison pour laquelle je
rends mon bébé est mort tard mon oiseau
est incomplète il
ah ah ah c'est horrible mais quelle
salle où il ya rien à faire ou plus
c'est horrible j'adore voir des gens qui
ont des oiseaux comme ça et qui sont pas
en cash c'est l'oiseau il est libre dans
la partie se baladent voire même il fait
un petit tour dehors il revient c'est la
bonne manière d'avoir un oiseau choquant
et immédiatement désolé de ce que tu as
fait c'est quoi l'histoire c'est le
chacal est trop loin
[Musique]
aa et mec ça me touche mais je crois que
je découvre je découvre que j'ai je
flippe un peu des chats qui sont énervés
c'est quand ils ont les poils qui se
dressent la queue qui gonfle et tout le
temps je suis pas bien je vous jure je
suis pas bien cinq lits et presque dix
chaises confortables dans cette maison
donc août a décidé de s'asseoir sur les
pépins d'oeuvre épique déjà mais c'est
le coup classique du tu achètes un jouet
pour ton chat et il va jouer avec le
carton dans lequel étaient emballés de
jouer mais avec le jouer c'est là
exactement une chose wouah ou non il
s'en veut oh non il s'en veut et
comprend qu'il est allé trop loin mais
qu'il a fait une retournée fun envers
les chiens ils comprennent que quand ils
tendent leur cul vers l'ennemi ils ont
l'avantagé parce que du coup leur point
faible donc leur tête est loin et
peuvent se contient que leur cul mais
lui il est passé au stade supérieur lui
la concubine est une arme redoutable qui
plus est au pied ça avec a oublié ses
clés dans la voiture et de la voiture il
ya plus que son chien et du coup je
pense qu'il essaie de commandes son
chien d'ouvrir la porte ça n'arrivera
jamais évidemment que c'est une crise
j'adore le regarder comment ça s'est
passé comme si le chien de déverrouiller
les portes ces experts
[Applaudissements]
waouh mec c'est vraiment un live gold
fou genre quel chien déverrouille la
voiture de son titre c'est incroyable
par contre ça n'a rien à faire dans
cette vidéo
parce que là du coup je commence à avoir
vraiment de la peine pour nous tous et
sa collerette ça fait chier
revoyons des animaux qui se comportent
comme des connards la même les bébé
rhinocéros en mer leur maman de temps à
autre je connais pas le de rinôçérôse
games pour être en règle ou alors on va
il a la fougue il est jeune il se laisse
aller quoi petit con comme le démon ne
s'arrête pas mais tu es là tu es là
carrément à non non ça va souvent les
chiens qui font 40 50 kg quand ils
viennent de grandir donc en 4 mois de
prendre 20 kilos mais ils n'ont pas
conscience de leur force et de leur
taille leur poids et ça se voit dans
leur comportement avec les autres genres
y met des gifles du mental sans se
rendre compte qu'elle était monumentale
la gifle salamandre hall des corbeaux
interrompt la météo ice époque il s'est
posé sur la cam là bas c'est loin d'être
con ces animaux je vous le dis
[Musique]
waouh [ __ ] il s'est pris un coup de
dauphin lachance moi aussi je prends un
couteau enfin un chien n'a pas laissé
pape a jeté le sapin de noël elle bob me
battre ils maîtrisent totalement un
s'avérer des cages et intrigues devant
un chien tout son cerveau s'éveille
j'adore voici notre chat charlotte elle
n'a aucune limite et ne ressent aucune
honte qui pense que charlotte a raison
oui le nouveau-né on s'en fout tu étais
là bien avant charlotte tu leur apporter
bien plus d'amour que je devenais le
fera
[Musique]
il fait genre il s'étire mais l'adage on
a tous vu ça fait mal les schirmeck et
des experts pour faire genre qui l'ont
pas fait exprès quelque chose alors
qu'ils ont totalement calculé cd proulx
pour ça jean même nature ne le fait pas
je lui dis à la gauche il a compris
quand je lui dis mais il fait le genre
qui l'a pas entendu et continue tout
droit pour que la balade soit un peu
plus longue
j'adore je déteste et j'adore à la fois
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les couilles l'arrière il veut jouer en
tout cas heureusement il peut compter
sur le soutien de sa copine un cas l'air
affolé par ce qui se passe pas du tout
un grizzly qui s'approprie toute la
route
waouh en même temps mais qui va aller
lui dire de dégager la route qui une
tortue énerve étape la chaussure de
quelqu'un les animaux quand ils ont un
message à faire passer et ne le font pas
ces gens c'est trop à ça j'adore mec je
kiffe les vidéos ou genre les animaux
ils sont en train de faire une connerie
mais ils ont pas vu que le maître a
grillé qui s'entraîne comme un mélange
de culpabilité de regret de pitié vinci
génial hein il a volé des chips son
regard va être fou je le sens
[Musique]
viator bon dans ce bris dit charmant je
suis rentré de bonnes son geste mais ça
vous a plu je vais maintenant rentrer
regardez natsu malheureusement en me
disant toujours pourquoi ça va donc pas
du tout marché mais j'ai quand même
passé un très bon moment je dédie cette
vidéo à tous vos animaux qui ont eu ou
quiconque une collerette voilà et bisous
avant mamie qui s'appelle colada annoncé
colette au hockey allez c'est chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]